point one to this video playing our
penguin with white and see what you get
CC and Cara to Drupal decade oh yeah
this is a very solid line for black that
is some fortunately not that often
played that's really very okay for black
yeah okay Queen f4 is what you usually
do in
Jeff night h5 cycle Quincy wanna quit to
be eight it makes a lot of sense trade
queen okay not much to do about it but I
think the center here I don't mind the
double panel that much that gives
additional central control how do I play
from here good night to d5 I would still
like to do I wonder if 94 as I move for
him to simplify more yeah I feared that
but I couldn't really i didn't see
anything else 793 anyway you can still
try things in this position
hmm not exactly a book that i had only
agenda maybe he wants to go to see five
and I go to default yeah well okay my
knight on d4 fortunately is not badly
positioned I wonder about 96 that maybe
he can do that try it you more okay my
here maybe this is a bit annoying fun
night I hidden ip5 salt
night will come to defy that it's nicely
placed
yeah p is not only six it's not badly
positioned can i get for f5 would be
nice to play and but that's not easy
maybe i can do this now if for forget it
is at least aggressive yeah i do want to
trade so I return I wonder about 96 now
until now is a practice text matches a
group g1 in the night has no move
because of mate
but it would work now actually have to
move the night taking doesn't work at
all i think so we have to move it now
and then i have 95
may take root g 1 and this night cannot
move I'm probably threatening at six and
disposition which would be quite awkward
if he takes light if there's a fork
that's an interesting defense ok over
here yeah mmmm interesting if I think I
could try to sec the exchange the
probably won't work huh I wonder if
night f4 is good here or not that it's
tricky to say I do I'll do this they
probably have to take and now what is he
doing there taking here my position is a
bit more active but is he's very solid
and I could have taken there ok first
first things first so he's kicking up
the pond why is that I mean I understand
he doesn't want to defend passively with
still on surprised ok
[Music]
I can take us to actually but ok it
wouldn't have helped all that much yeah
this is a good mood film I know you
can't say that I can we can take action
which it doesn't do that hoop black well
yeah that was a bit weird end John I
felt I had slight crush i have very very
slight pressure nothing or too serious
just okay so i tried to see phone at
five stuff then there was some some
pressure but he defended this I felt
rather well and now I was super here I
couldn't consider book h7 actually went
okay and I was surprised that he gave
away the pawn and it is totally not bad
and that looks passive and really does
okay so he went for the active defense
and the engine wants to do this to have
this plane hmm and it makes quite some
sense am if you check this check there
is definitely good for black I mean
equal equal
okay and here i can i can try stuff at
least but it's a bit awkward yeah he
could have taken on f2 who have taken
him surprised that the engine gives like
an edge share maybe i cannot i cannot
really defend a pond so awkward yeah so
we should have done that in PA sir yeah
it was a pretty weird yeah blunder look
quite quite uncommon with this motif ok
guys thanks for watching i was a bit of
a lucky win